Ми спочатку війни до початку війни
почали обговорювати пункт укриття А
зараз це вже переходить на пункт
обігріву та пункту незламності
мешканці цього Київського ОСББ склалися
грошима і закупили усе необхідне для
того щоб їхня багатоповерхівка на
близько півтисячі квартир стала
автономною за відсутності будь-яких
комунальних благ світла опалення
електрики та води на сьогоднішній момент
в нас є Польова кухня є генератор
трьохфазний 7 кВт також в нас є 60 ліжок
якої комісії 30 ліжок двох'ярусних У нас
є 10 тонн запасу води та дві станції
фільтрації для приготування питної води
головна мета дати будинку замерзнути
Тому зараз планують купити ще один
великий генератор на 50-60 кіловат щоб
котельня могла працювати автономно Якщо
нам удасться купити великий генератор у
нас буде в будинку тепло
працювати І буде тепло і буде вода а це
вистачить енергії від того генератора на
дві котельні на два теплопунти на
освітлення місць загального користування
і на підкачку насосів для води у
підвалах для людей облаштували укриття
тут є ліжка опалення електрика й
інтернет за таких умов у підвалі можна
провести від кількох днів до кількох
тижнів своє укриття ОСББ навіть вирішило
подати в офіційний реєстр пунктів
незламності
пункти обігрів їх ще не було як ми вже
працювали
зараз коли вже стало питання по Каждому
району Одеської і в якому районі скільки
там пунктів обігрів
я його подав в реєстр мені хочеться щоб
Люди бачили і відповідно кажемо подумав
А давайте ми хочемо собі зробимо може не
так менше але це було би і для людей і
меншим навантаження було і на ту саму
державу держава це ми ми
тому під час блекауту сюди пускатимуть
їй інших мешканців міста скільки в нас
місць скільки людей пустимо та кілька
годин зарядити в нас
wi-fi тут є від провайдера але в нас вже
є старлінг
От і Ми зараз робимо розводку і в нас на
перших поверхах в обох секціях буде буде
wi-fi і тут буде wi-fi у цей пункт
незламності вже привезли гуманітарну
допомогу для тих хто прийде сюди
зігрітися
чайник стаканчики чаї
цукерки шоколадки тут є і печеня вода ну
і засоби гігієни якщо бачите то
паперові рушники це дитячі памперси
памперси для дорослих
мило і тому подібне
в ОСББ і пропитну воду у власній
насосній поставили спеціальні фільтри
тут розташовані баки вони заповнені тут
5 тонн води
в кожній секції це друга секція є ще
перша секція там також 5 тонн води Ось
стоїть обратний осмос який видає
30 літрів на хвилину
він виготовляє нам питну питна вода вже
вже на фільтровані там от є бочки Там
вже з 210 літрів питної води стоїть
кухні вже закупили дрова А у підвалі
встановили буржуйки які допоможуть не
лише обігріти приміщення а й закип'ятити
воду те що ви бачили з вулиці трудову
оце буржуйка вона розрахована 50
квадратних метрів обігріву таких буржу
як буде встановлено 4 одна тут одна
навпроти і дві в передній частині це ми
перший такий пробний зробили
тест Ну добре гріє
розпалювали її вже
у такому укритті зможе розміститися до
тисячі людей разом із підвалом тут є ще
два спортзали які також можна займати ви
можете подивитися тут нас
душова
є туалет
Ну от тут
люди прямо на цих матах вони теплі вони
прямо на цих матах лежали діти бігали
для того щоб мешканці будинку спокійно
пережили зиму ОСББ вже інвестувало
півмільйона гривень власний пункт
незламності вони створили ще до того як
такі центри по всій країні почала
ініціювати Влада нині на інтерактивній
карті позначена вже понад 4 тисячі
пунктів незламності це місця для
тимчасового перебування де затрималого
відключення електроенергії чи тепла
обіцяють безкоштовний доступ до
електрики опалення інтернету води та
аптечок ні вранці мені взяла вдалося
зловити кілька поділок в мережі щоб
дізнатися де поруч є такі пункти
незламності І врешті понад кілометрів
йшла сюди щоб знайти впіймати бодай
кілька полосок в мережі щоб зв'язатися з
близькими щоб погрітися І взагалі випити
вода якогось чаю тому що ми вже живемо
без світла понад добу щоправда не всі
пункти незламності позначені на мапі
були готовими до прийому мешканців
Багато з них не відкрилися або не були
забезпечені усіма обіцяними благами
через це президент Володимир Зеленський
навіть дорікнув Київській владі за
профанацію і погане забезпечення пунктів
незламності у столиці накритику з боку
президента мер Києва Віталій Кличко
відповів що в нинішній ситуації не хоче
вступати в політичні баталії і повідомив
що в столиці облаштовані та працюють
понад 430 пунктів обігріву А на випадок
надзвичайної ситуації готується
оперативно розгорнути ще понад 100
пунктів тим часом українці знаходять
альтернативні варіанти кав'ярні з
генераторами чи коворкінг центри ми
підключили невеличкий генератор який у
нас вже був доступ і ми зараз чекаємо
великих генератор на 100+ кВт він майже
як машина за розміром він у нас буде
біля парковки розташований А зараз ми
просто на терасу підключили невеличкий
генератор пустили багато подовжувачів і
в цій зоні Зараз який ми знаходимось всі
працювали у таких місцях люди можуть не
лише провести кілька щоб зарядити
гаджети і випити чаю а й повноцінно
працювати саме в цьому коворкінгу в нас
є в принципі всі можливості для того щоб
працювати ефективно для того щоб не
зупиняти свою роботу і продовжувати
комунікувати Ну ми практично тут живемо
у нас тут є і капсули для сна і душеві і
кава і wi-fi і все на світі допомагати
українцям готовий і відповідальний
бізнес дедалі частіше магазини аптеки
заправки банки поштові відділення та
ресторани долучаються і відкривають у
себе пункти незламності перелік адрес
можна знайти на онлайн-карті Та можна
зігрітися і зарядити пристрої інші ж
послуги надають за окрему плату